it's all about bright bright is a
fantasy cop thriller you play an elf and
you play a badass elf yeah in this film
it's the villain you are really
impressive in that the the stunts that
you're doing and what you physically go
through in this role is really
impressive really impressive we have a
clip here from bright anything we need
to know I believe this is a scene where
you are the villain and I think Will
Smith is in this scene and you guys are
gonna kill each other
yes I'm chasing him I'm the villain I
mean I'm she surname is Layla and I'm
dressed in his amazing suits really high
heels
so we rehearsal the stunt scenes like
you know in trainers and you have a
track suit and you know when you have to
squeeze yourself into like a super slim
suit yeah my heels and yeah you know so
I was working with teeth we have like
contact lenses elf ears so a lot of
things that made like the fight scenes
kind of hard but um but it was it was
amazing it was really fun in this scene
we're gonna see is in in a gas station
and I'm trying to kill Will Smith trying
to kill ya Will Smith yeah he actually
plays Will Smith in the movie it's a
very bizarre jerk but you'll see let's
say who this clip from bright yeah
[Applause]
nah
[Music]
these are those are those are not the
elves I grew up with right will be
available in select theaters and on
Netflix starting December 22nd thank you
so much for being here thank you yeah I
love talking to you new me prepare to be
right back Gary Clark jr. is here
you